i'm in real time right now i've got
something on my plate that's
you know i was when we talked the other
yet a couple days ago steve i was out in
el centro looking at the border the
the trump wall you know yeah danny calls
you up the other day
and uh i'm like oh yeah dude just came
back from like getting hitting the balls
like and he's like oh i'm getting ready
to jump over a [ __ ] border wall
i'm like dude we're old you know we're
older we're still
doing this [ __ ] you know dude who would
have thought you know i mean like when i
was a kid like
you know the guys that were 30 skating
we were like
look at this old man trying to skate
dude and i'm looking at bucky at
47 or whatever just ripping and many new
tricks
it's a different era dude it's like i
didn't even thought we would get to this
point and like
i'm sure like we were living by day by
day when we were younger like it didn't
it wasn't like a five-year plan or a
three-year plan it was like
a 24-hour plan for sure and when when we
were kids
there was no such thing as like a rock
star
over 30 or an athlete over 30 right like
you
yeah i mean maybe the [ __ ] rolling
stones are like we're
40. i don't know but that was [ __ ] up
i mean it definitely you know things
have evolved in this area you know like
you can
yeah it's it's pretty cool that we're
able to still you know
you get kicked in the balls amigo you
know try and make these wall jumps
nothing
i mean since you brought it up like
what's the story with the
the trump border wall like what's the
i mean i i'm not like a politic guy so
it's don't
i hope people don't you know i i'm
actually wrong
it's it's shock value it's like okay
there's controversial
over the wall there's controversy over
the you know the pre
all the elections right now and you
would probably understand this more than
anyone
from like um from like a you know a
media standpoint
there's other things that you know that
that would be nice to shine light on
like
you know the border you know politics
separate people the border separates
people based on politics but the people
are you know my friend that
races trophy trucks who's mexican is the
one that got us the permission on
the mexico side so we were both going to
jump it he's going to jump in in his
trophy truck i'm going to jump it on my
skateboard
but the idea is is like it's a mexican
and an american jumping it it's like
we're all good dude the politics
separated that's not people people
people the people we love each other
there's no separation i like that
so what you're going to do the same
thing like you did in the great wall of
china
yeah this is a little different uh it's
a little different style because of how
what the wall is it's just a different
layer like type of wall it's like to me
it's really tall
to me it would be funnier if like there
wasn't a wall because isn't there like
not a wall or yeah is there a wall
dude this wall's like 40 feet tall with
like barbed wire like
it's a gnarly is it new gnarly stunt i
feel like that gives more
credit than is deserved though because i
don't think trump's built [ __ ]
right that's something that's just
always been there huh he's built some
stuff
and he started they started building it
in like san ysidro right but you know
the border between
you know imperial beach and san diego
but we went out
east a little bit because we know people
that own private property out there i'm
working with like the head of the border
patrol and
um and i've been working with the mayor
of imperial beach and like we've been
trying to hone our team to get this done
but it's going to be a lot easier to do
on private property than federal
property so i found these
locations that we know people who own
these these properties but they're
east a little bit but the wall there is
pre-existing although it's still
35 feet tall and five feet of barbed
wire on the top of it
i don't know where the [ __ ] trump thinks
he needs to build a different wall this
wall
is serious dude like it's no joke i'm
like looking at this thing like what
why would you need to replace this wall
so funny if anything get rid of it all
together but
yeah dude